let's review our objectives kill the
robots and don't die
don't die it's just something you want
to do every day it's still an objective
if i may we have one objective we need
to put this crystal in the turnip and
get out of here so to do that we have to
get onto the base to do that we have to
kill all the robots to do that we have
to destroy the zerg ship and to do any
of that we have to not die
um derek allow me to explain operation
surprise party it is a variation on
operation thundersphere didn't you get a
medal for that one two actually but uh
wait how do you know about operation
thundersphere i've read all my grandma's
space ranger books from cover to cover
twice excuse me robot kitty cat sorry
sensors have indicated that dessert ship
powers the robots on the ground so we
fly up there we blow up the ship and
surprise robots you're toast then we put
your crystal in the tournament and
finish the mission
it's a good plan
to infinity
are you trying to get me to pull your
finger don't fall for it no not like
that it was ugh sorry it's a thing your
grandma and i used to do yeah
i we never she didn't mean to anyway
forget it